I sometimes don't like to wait for the
bathroom because up my sister's in there
or something so I just pee in these
bottles and she said he had logic I
can't judge I peed in a bucket in the
garage there was like a
mini you guys still want to get rid of
bullying
an Illinois woman reported her husband
missing in April
and ended up finding his mummified
remains eight months later while looking
for Christmas decorations mummified
mummified what preserved like properly
mummified like just not I don't think I
think improperly it's a sarcophagus
what the heck wait what's mummified is
it like not decomposed but preserved
what is it was it wrapped like there's
four no I didn't uh check the definition
but what do you what's your definition
oh this says mummified so I read it
remove the organs put it in a part you
know this guy's never hosted before
ancient Egyptians I wonder if there's a
way to accidentally mummify yourself
dude we're gonna start accidentally yeah
cut a hole in your ass and then watch
your organ drop out I'm trying to figure
out
preserve during the gentleman's era of
JK I think that stupid questions will be
responded to with a beating to death
wait are we in the gym I want to talk
about
yeah that's what Joe called it the
gentleman's era at this time that's what
we're is this is that the air we're in
right now koi look at him I think he was
trying to force [__] it into the
situation a little bit he's like you're
more than a gentleman oh he's calling
you out he's forcing it he's calling you
is that what I said last time
I made up an era but I forgot what we
call it the gentleman's area okay we're
gentlemen as the JK historian I I
cataloged all of this all right now
there's gonna be a coffee table books
coming out next year so no he's
mummified right eight months after being
missing she finds him looking for
Christmas decorations in The Hideaway
Closet in her home hey you know what oh
[__] she did it dude what she did it so
apparently not but why would you give
yourself I'll be like I found him eight
months later because you know some
people like some criminals like we've
covered stories like this where like
they'll just kind of do something that
they think they'll get away with yeah
it's right under my nose the whole time
it's like someone who farted and blamed
other people imagine she found him and
his his hand is like this because he's
still looking for the Chris
himself in Christmas lights if somebody
in your household went missing wouldn't
you look through the whole house
especially the closet it's always the
last place I honestly I think it's fair
to say Pantry dude there is something
fishy going on yeah
in the house though so this guy was
reported missing April 27th one day
after calling his wife to tell her he's
leaving work early she told the police
she returned that day to find his truck
parked outside their house with his
wallet and keys left behind but no
traces of her husband and hasn't heard
from him since police initially surfed
searched the residents which they
described as a hoarder house oh
so he was buried in all the junk
crushed alive dude they found they found
a thing but they did notice a sewer-like
odor inside the home but they couldn't
they couldn't find out where it was
coming so it already stank right
everything stiff and you know what
happened this is how he died dude you
guys ever seen Uncle Buck oh [__] what
was that that was scary that's how he
died yeah he opens up the like the
closet bowling ball hits him
home alone dead home alone so how did he
die a ornament hits him in his head but
the mummification is the mystery like if
his body was just oh I got cracked it's
cold where he's at and it snows so he
got mummified he also could just be
packed perfectly between Christmas
decorations yeah like it's about
indo-box in such a way yeah yeah instead
of it closed and it Raffles and it
wrapped him up like you know what
hoarders when they clean out their house
and they find a bunch of dead cats yeah
and they're like just like that yeah
they find
I think it just starves to death and it
runs out of junk to eat it's like under
like the cat doesn't leave the house no
I don't think they would be able to
because they found it dead my mom lost
my phone I'm just trying to talk about
all these people who love cats or like
cats are smarter than dogs and I'm like
a dog will [__] leave the house if
there's no [__] food I don't know
about that I had a mummified frog well
because my mom she lost my frog when she
was like helping me clean out the tank
and then I was out playing got
distracted add you know and I came back
and she's like I'm so sorry I lost your
frog and I was like [__] I was over it
right and then one day we were cleaning
right how big is the Frog it was like
this big okay frog size it was like this
it was like a tiny frog oh oh like a one
day we were cleaning the living room and
then my mom found them under the couch
there Frozen [__] I mean a mummified
crispy [__] dried up oh [__] yeah
Preserve
no like this oh just [__] was that
the last frog Jersey jerky what was that
the last time
no he thought about it speaking of add
so sometimes sometimes later
the the and that wasn't to Joe by the
way this room is wild today
let's let's try to stick to this a
little bit okay so Steve's saying that
we're in trouble bro so she a hoarder
right calls the cops to complain about a
[__] odor when a when a hoarder calls
the cops that means it's bad that's
rough because they live in [__] exactly
so then they Circle a second time
favorite scent then a plumber gets
called to the house to put a cap on a
sewer pipe in the basement which was a
suspected source of the odor and it
doesn't help
so then you know basically months go by
no sign of the guy his wife's looking
for Christmas decorations on December 11
she told police she went to go access a
storage area and she was looking for
their Frosty the Snowman six-footer
behind the clothes in a crowded closet
under a six foot Frosty the Snowman
outdoor ornament that is where she found
her husband holy [__] it was Frosty and
apparently he was staring at it too
that's [__] up was he like looking at
and like staring at him do they have
this is getting scary do they have the
cause of death by chance staring in a
Frosty's cold
so apparently he had committed suicides
what the coroner said oh but how did he
drink mummification liquid and then he's
like I'm going to bed he drank Mercury
he drank formaldehyde doesn't say it
says pending toxicology results but they
believe it was a suicide it was only a
matter of time dude because I'm sure he
probably didn't want to live in that
house porterhouse dude living in a
whorehouse is probably have you guys
been to anybody's actual hoarder house
I've seen porterhouse I've seen I've
seen shows really my parents are you
raised [__] hoarders bro that like
really bad though 100 not like Thrift
Shop hoarder like how bad what are they
like an antique shop for bad enough
where like there's no corner of the
house that didn't have [__] in it wait
let me ask you this can you see the
floor of your home yeah yeah it's not
like [__] though what were they
collecting it's like they got chicken
feed on the ground and [__] somewhere
[Laughter]
everywhere dead cats no not like that
but like definitely like what the [__]
is this emotional or just like random
stuff you're random stuff do you feel
like that changed how you live your life
like are you a complete minimalist Yes
except for all that bling on you
[__] yeah exactly right no like
pie you know what Nikki and I are both
the same way thank God like where we
both don't want a bunch of [__] yeah but
when you guys go over for like family
gatherings how's their space you guys
have to move all the Train toys and
that's where they're supposed to be so
my mom if she knew we were coming home I
could end up bringing Nikki home she
would clean up but like you know it's
like it's like organizing a mess
you know what I mean yeah so it's like
okay it still looks like a thrift store
basically but like it's like got aisles
yeah but it's not like those cramp dials
like where it's like you you have to
look sideways walk or anything it's like
you could live inside of it but it's
kind of whack it's not optimal yeah it
makes you feel stressed out of there
it's like what the [__] yeah it's like
my neighbor my neighbor has drugstore
lighting like this oh no no no no why he
says he puts in all the houses that he
gets and I'm like it's good for your
skin it gives me a headache dude stuff
that's good fluorescent too much blue
light makes me feel like I'm working in
an office when I go to his house I feel
like I'm visiting my parents but that's
the kind of thing your environment can
stress you out and so I think hoarder
[__] could could drive someone to
Suicide was there a note was there a
suicide note no no dude what if it's the
opposite what if it's the opposite and
he loved his stuff so much he's like I
want to just die in it like that's what
they did the Egyptians you bury them
with your goods so maybe he valued his
Christmas he wanted to go with his Goods
does it say he was Egyptian yeah he's
Egyptian well mummification is such a
specific word I know yeah that's what
I'm saying like why did he get mummified
I think people just get dried out to
your point they say that he had dried up
enough the fluids were removed from the
skin which could explain why the remains
didn't have as strong an odor over time
and why it took so long for his body to
be found yeah rotten food in there too
in the house I don't think so I don't
know I remember watching hoarders and
they were there was this guy that would
save his [__] and piss huh save it
because you hoarded that dude because he
doesn't want to waste any he would save
his urine or he would put stuff in a jar
and then urinate in the jar yeah like
like uh you know so you have and they
would he would just have [__] [__]
glass jars and bottles of just [__] and
piss dude I have a story about a friend
that I found out did that why and it was
really disturbing they're not your
friend anymore but why did they do that
it was back in high school we thought
it'd be funny to go to a friend's house
this is when screamed the movie was like
huge so he bought a scream mask and we
went to his window and we were just
stood there with it and he was like oh
[__] and then um he uh he had to invite
us in because we were all there laughing
we went into his room and in his room
there was just a ton of water bottles
filled with piss what yeah is this was
he living at home was
was living at home and then we were like
he didn't want to go to the bathroom so
we asked him we were like why do you
have why do you pee in these bottles how
yellow was it and he was like super
embarrassed and he was like he should be
he I guess like he did it so much he
forgot that he did it and then like you
know like when people do [__] like that
they're not thinking of it all the time
that's why you need friends it's just
mental health baby yeah it just hit him
that we saw it all and then he was like
I sometimes don't like to wait for the
bathroom because up my sister's in there
or something so I just pee in these
bottles and she said he had logic I
can't judge
there was like a
like I'll keep that many you guys still
want to get rid of bullying
I'm gonna ask a couple questions
assuming the house had only one bathroom
I don't know if it did but there was a
bathroom right next to his room and he's
his excuse was that his sister was
always in it but a Hundred Bottles like
apparently she was because she's not
clowning his ass like you got to throw
him out sometime yeah or what about like
just peeing in the woods or just outside
outside I peed outside this morning
that's why I think some some people just
do [__] they just like that they're
doing it and then yeah and it becomes
like this weird shame you're still
friends with this person no I'm not
he broke the world record for spinning
on his head oh [__]
like song My Song
[Music]
foreign